Wager that a good number of artists and
ambitious creative people like myself
spend a dreadful amount of time
considering their legacy.
How will I be remembered what works of
mine,
if any,
will carry on into posterity,
immortality through art,
to give you a sense of time.
If Shakespeare wrote Romeo and Juliet
today,
critics and all lovers of the written
word would still be pouring over.
It's possible meanings in the year.
Twenty four,
31 a.
If Plato uploaded the republic onto the
kindle library this afternoon,
political scholars would still be
debating it's efficacy in 44,
oh,
eight.
Or as it's popularly known,
you're 92 after the pen.
Galactic Battle of Gemini Centaury Long
live.
The Republican,
the yearning for such immortality is no
doubt a stupid enterprise born of some
combination of narcissism,
insecurity,
and the fear of death,
and it doesn't even solve the real
problem.
As Woody Allen said,
I don't want to achieve immortality
through my work.
I want to achieve immortality through
not dying.
Of course,
the appealing thing about having your
work live on is that presumably it's the
best part of you and history can
graciously forget the rest.
I want my ads yet unwritten,
great American novel to achieve
posthumous a claim,
not this picture of me and the raccoon
that was apparently living on my head.
Some things we want to be forgotten.
Well,
that's easier said than done in the
Internet age.
In 1998,
the Spanish newspaper,
Lavonne,
Guardian,
published a local announcement about the
forced sale of a home due to outstanding
social security debts.
The property and the debts belong to a
Spanish lawyer named Mario Gonzales in
2009 11 years later.
Gonzalez didn't appreciate that even
then when you searched his name on
Google,
what you saw at the top of the results
was this small financial lapse from the
late nineties.
Didn't he have a right for that
information to be?
Last Gonzalez contacted Lavonne.
Guardian asked for them to take the
story down.
They said no.
So he filed a complaint with the Spanish
data protection agency asking for the
paper to remove the story and also for
Google to do the same from its search
engines.
The agency director rejected the request
to the newspaper,
but upheld the one to google,
telling them to remove the links and
make access to that data impossible.
After some wrangling and appeals,
the highest court in the European Union
supported the agency directors demand
saying that Google was responsible for
the processing of personal data and that
people had a right to erasure or a right
to be forgotten.
So what's your instinctive reaction to
this?
Maybe you feel a strong sympathy for
decent people who are just trying to get
out from under the shadow of the
worldwide web who want their pasts to be
private.
On the other hand,
do we want business people handling our
money,
for example,
to be able to erase a prior bankruptcy
or a politician to delete some troubling
behavior from the past.
The problem with the court's ruling is
that the boundaries for lodging a
complaint are so incredibly vague and
open to interpretation.
The court only says the information
which is no longer relevant or timely
can be erased,
but who gets to decide that American
legal scholars are confident that such a
law would not be passed in the states
where free speech protected by the First
Amendment is champion more readily than
each individual's right to privacy,
though both are precious to us.
A recent pew study found that 68 percent
of American internet users believe
current laws are not good enough in
protecting people's privacy online,
and 86 percent have taken steps to mask
their digital footprint.
Privacy is not a word that appears in
the US Constitution.
The right to privacy is a relatively
recent concept introduced by Louis
Brandeis in an essay in the Harvard law
review from 1890.
This question is really hard to work out
what effects do my demands to have this
picture of me doing?
A keg stand taken off some random blog,
have on an open and free internet.
It's not readily apparent,
but when Google or facebook are burden
with that choice at the peril of fines
are worse than the path of least
resistance may be to say,
just take it down and I think we can all
see the slippery slope in that.
In the description under worksighted.
I'll leave links to educated opinions on
both sides of this argument.
The US and Europe are primed.
It seems to go down different roads here
and I can't say which is the right one.
It's easy to choose between liberty and
constraint,
but to make a judgment call is much
harder when to liberties are at odds
with each other.
There's so many things to read about
this.
If nothing else,
checkout Louis.
Brandeis is essay on the right to
privacy.
It is just a seminal essay in the
history of law.
Comments below or ask me anything on
Tumbler.
I'll put the link in the description.
Thanks for watching.
I'll see you next Friday.